Десять в мінус шостій метра в квадраті.
Внизу сігма рівна F поділене на S.
Ці формули з біомеханіки, як і матеріал на всіх інших заняттях,
першокурсниця Львівського медичного університету,
полячка Альдона Глова вивчає українською.
Вона перша в історії цього вишу іноземка, яка навчається
на рівні з українцями на бюджетній формі.
Складно навчатися іншою мовою.
Але якщо звикаєш до того, це не є так дуже складно.
Під час війни я спілкувалася з українцями, і таким чином
вчилася української мови.
Україна завжди була якась мені близька. Почуваю себе тут добре.
Також суспільство тут дуже відкрите.
Улітку Альдона успішно склала вступні іспити українською
і з вересня навчається у Львові. Вона потрапила на навчання
за новою освітньою програмою для громадян Польщі в Україні,
за якою поляки прирівнюються до українців
під час вступу в університет. Торік її започаткували за законом,
ініційованим Офісом Президента України.
Я не знала, що тут така можливість є.
Взагалі випадково знайшла таку інформацію.
Це не було дуже легко - сюди приїхати і вступити в університет.
Це страшно, треба сказати, особливо, якщо тривоги.
Але я вже відвідувала Львів під час війни.
Я її питала: "Чому в Європу не їдете? А до нас - все ж таки ризиковано".
А вона каже, що в нас знання дають, у нас є практичні заняття.
Дитина повністю адаптована! Різниці немає між україномовними
і студенткою, яка приїхала з іншої країни.
Більшість іноземних вступників до Львівського медичного університету
цього року - це саме громадяни Польщі, кажуть в адміністрації вишу.
Але поляки - далеко не єдині іноземці тут.
Англійською в цьому виші продовжують навчатися ще понад
чотири сотні іноземців з 18 країн світу.
Картеке евакуювався через Угорщину до рідної Індії у перший тиждень
після вторгнення РФ. Але вже за два місяці повернувся назад до Львова.
Я особисто приїхав, тому що не хотів навчатися в іншій країні,
бо я тут жив і навчався чотири роки до цього.
До війни ми могли літати додому прямо з України.
Зараз до Індії ми можемо дістатися тільки через іншу країну,
тож це єдина незручність.
Зараз дуже важко отримати транзитну візу.
Здебільшого саме через ускладнену логістику та безпекові ризики
у зв'язку з війною Україна втратила 38% студентів-іноземців.
Крім того, більшість вишів повністю відмовилися приймати
на навчання студентів з Росії та Білорусі.
Станом на сьогодні в українських університетах очно
і дистанційно навчається понад 50 тисяч іноземців.
Найбільше - з Китаю та Індії. На думку директорки
Українського державного центру міжнародної освіти,
така статистика в часи війни краща за очікувану.
Збережені освітні контракти з іноземцями дозволяють
і надалі частково підтримувати забезпечення самих університетів.
Якщо ми говоримо про студентів-медиків, то в середньому
це 4 з половиною тисячі доларів на рік.
Це досить серйозні інвестиції в заклади освіти України.
І насправді до того, як трапилася така трагедія
і повномасштабне вторгнення, були розмови про те,
що іноземні студенти приїжджають сюди іноді легко отримати диплом,
бо вони не хочуть навчатися. І саме повномасштабне вторгнення
показало, що іноземні студенти хочуть навчатися.
Понад 60% сказали, що вони готові повернутися в будь-який момент,
який їм дозволять і скажуть, що тут більш-менш безпечно.
Зараз лише п'ята частина серед усіх студентів-іноземців
фізично присутня на заняттях в Україні, переважно у західних
та центральних регіонах.
Здебільшого це саме студенти-медики, дипломи яких більшість країн
не визнає, якщо вони здобуті дистанційно.
Бюджетність навчання і проживання в Україні - також важлива
мотивація для іноземців. А часом причина повернутися
в Україну… безпекова.
Приміром, студент медичного вишу з Лівану Асад
повернувся на заняття у Львів місяць тому і планує залишатися тут
до випускного, бо його рідний регіон межує з Ізраїлем,
і ситуація з безпекою там ще критичніша.
Усі з нас бояться війни. Тож, у цій ситуації батьки намагаються
захистити своїх доньок і синів від небезпеки.
Гадаю, тут безпечніше наразі. У нас є інші варіанти,
але не всі країни надають візу, як в Україні.
Не всі країни мають такі ціни, як тут - близько 4 тисяч доларів на рік.
У Польщі або Італії, приміром, це буде 15 тисяч євро.
Ціна навчання в Україні дійсно дуже хороша, порівняно з іншими країнами.
Україна - це як другий дім для мене. І Україна вийде
з цієї війни ще сильнішою і успішнішою!
Студентка з Нігерії Елет ще у перші дні повномасштабної війни
була впевнена, що продовжить навчання тут
і житиме в місцевому гуртожитку далі.
Хтось забирав звідси свої речі, але я усе залишила
і потім усе було на місці.
Я чула, що деякі українці з інших міст знаходили прихисток
в наших кімнатах, доки нас не було.
Першокурсниця з Польщі Альдона Глова мешкає у сусідньому гуртожитку.
Там цьогоріч зробили ремонт у крилі для іноземців,
а також обладнали нове укриття.
Вартість проживання на місяць - дві з половиною тисячі гривень.
Звідси дівчині зручно їздити на вихідні додому у рідний Жешув.
Мені взагалі не дуже багато треба. Є гарний букетик квітів,
і вже почуваю себе краще.
У Польщі квартири і гуртожитки зовсім інакше виглядають.
Але я тут все, чого потребую, маю.